so first of all
Let's Express.
these two machines mathematically
So now we are looking at exercise 1.
So this is
normal distribution
distribution
exercise one
it says
the first
machine
has mean of three centimeters.
standard deviation of 0.1 centimeters to express
this mathematically you say
that your random variable we would use x we
would use x sub 1 so we have two machines.
Both machines produce corrects, so they will have experiments
every time they produce a quirk right they're
producing. That's an experiment.
That's an experiment. So we will use a random variable to represent both
machines.
Since we have two we will use x sub 1 except two, you can use any random variable,
but we will just since X is used most
often and I want you to become familiar with the notation. We will use x
sub 1 and x sub 2 so x sub 1
okay has
That's what this.
Till they looking character means has normal
distribution.
And or was its divisions 0.1?
This is the first machine.
It's mean is three. It's standard deviation point one.
the other machine what you will represent using x sub 2
has normal distribution of
3.04
and
standard deviation of 0.02
Okay, so it's mean the the second machine the
second machine.
Okay.
it's a mean is towards the
towards the upper limit. So if you're looking at the numerically
and you go, oh my goodness the second the mean it
tends to have bigger bigger diameters. If
you're just looking at the mean on the other hand, the standard deviation is much narrow.
So it's less likely to deviate. Okay, just by looking just like
by looking at this notation you can you can figure out something you can
approximate something whereas the first machine is
right on three. It's like right in the center.
between 2.9 and 3.1
but it's standard deviation is
Greater at least when you compare it to
the second machine.
So this can clue you in on.
It's not enough for you to get a decide to.
Library conclusive answer but
If you know this notation.
That can give away a lot of information already.
Okay.
So x sub 1 and x sub 2 this is
the first machine second machine.
Now the next thing we want to look at.
We need to.
plot here
the other two pieces of information everybody that have
been that has been given to us is this
acceptable quirks have diameters between
2.9 centimeters and 3.1 centimeters so
we have to use this information.
For our standardized number valuable. So once we
will take x sub 1 x sub 2 standardize them.
And then see if the if they're experiments will
fall between 2.9 and 3.1. So let's assign these
two values to two constants.
So we'll come back.
You will let a
equal to 2.9.
and we will let actually let's put in the same place and let's
let B
equals to equal to 3.1
Okay, so after standardizing.
these random variables
We want them to fall between either 2.9 or 3 3.1 and
we want to know how many of their experiments will
fall within this range.